Film Courage: Forgive my naïveté, but why
does name talent not want to do [be in] horror
[movies]?
Is the budget too low or is there a stigma
attached?
Mark Heidelberger, Producer: I think named
talent is probably more adverse to horror
because of a stigma.
I don’t think it has to do with…because
some horror pictures have decent budgets and
I mean you could be going after maybe the
same names I’d be going after if it was
a romance or comedy on that same budget level.
So I don’t think it’s the money.
I do think it’s more the stigma.
My horror picture I had several casting directors
pass.
We had trouble finding a casting…we were
willing to pay them a decent salary and a
lot of them just didn’t want to take it
and I think because they felt like it was
going to be tough to get even a modest names
on board a horror movie…you know it’s
not like SE7EN where it’s like this smart
thriller with some kind of really pseudo horroresque
elements, it’s like straight horror, it’s
a tough sell and I think a lot of actors don’t
feel like maybe if they’re already established
that they need to do that genre, that it’s
going to help elevate their career, they want
to do more serious work or whatever that might
be.
I’m not saying I agree with that.
I think our picture THE BASEMENT I thought
had a really, unique interesting storyline.
Very psychological or it had some gruesome
moments but I think those gruesome moments
were enough to sort of scare people away.
So I think that stigma could be the managers
telling them look you don’t want to do horror
because the stigma is not real, perception
is reality.
So if it’s perceived enough to be there
then they’re just like better steer clear,
you’re getting offers on these other dramas,
romantic comedies, action pictures do those
because there is no stigma with those so go
ahead (they are safe).
That’s my assessment and if that’s a 100%
accurate but from what I’ve seen that’s
definitely actors avoiding horror pictures
outside of big studio ones are definitely
real because I’ve experience it firsthand
but that would be my assessment on why.